there's nothing better than a good old
intellectual debate there's a reason why
God gave you two ears in one mouth what
about you listen whatever your phone is
he's a thug your friend is a million
dollars not the last oh yeah where is it
buckle up wear it where is the seat I
should buckle to talk about the some
some fantasy criminal indictment you
don't know what you have no idea what
you're talking about
interrupting you laughing we love my
body speak tomorrow right can I speak
exactly what let me just sort of cut
through the testosterone that's like
cascading around me here please from him
Yeah right no that brings back memories
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes CNN you finally gone Springer all
that's missing is the hair-pulling and
the 300-pound bouncer maybe brian
Stelter candana referee sure I wonder
could this be what Anderson Cooper saw
as a career arc to go from high class to
crass and for what to prove Trump had
consensual sex not with his wife before
he became president I think America has
filed that under so what as for us you
won't hear a bad word about storming and
like Hillary and her friends we won't be
smirched the women we're gonna wait
until Trump has at least nine Oval
Office encounters with one of his
interns fresh out of college and until
he is accused of sexual assault by a
woman who came to him for help in the
meantime all we have is a story about a
robbed a decade ago at a golf tournament
but with Trump everyone knew his flaws
before they voted decades as a tabloid
staple didn't hurt as well as all those
prize-winning reporters now on the Trump
gossip beats and that Access Hollywood
tape helped funny that tape existed for
years tucked away in some creepy Network
dudes closet until it was leaked just
before an election what are the odds of
that
and so CNN sacrifices what's left of its
reputation trying to undo an election
they think if only people had another
chance to vote for Hillary they'd forget
about the woman who ridiculed her
husband's accusers Congrats CNN you've
redefined hard news so kg I think what
you're seeing in this anti Trump media
golf bag the Hitler Club didn't work
right the mental instability iron that
didn't work yep the chaos iron didn't
work the collusion putter failed so
bring the sex scandal wedge yes be
forgotten medical examination that's
right Sanjay yes so now we have this
it's like altima fighting championship
back and forth it's like crazy juban in
the middle very unsettling you know but
this is back and foot and when you look
at the poll numbers and what you're
asking people and women who support them
to think okay whatever what are you
doing
talking about this right now and they
say that they have evidence to proffer
that it better be something really
outrageous because now it's like they're
over promising and at risk of
under-delivering everyone got the big
hype about the CNN fantastic interview
with Anderson and there was nothing much
there whatsoever so I don't know what is
their point with all this they're trying
to undermine the American presidency
with this and say okay this was
something was consensual prior to him
being president United States etc one
situation and done okay now what where
do you go with this what are they trying
to do impeach the president with this or
they're just trying to again like dirty
the situation and muddy the waters you
know my favorite part I use the term
waters we just roll a little bit of tape
with mr. tubing no but I don't know yeah
I put him in this tub you know Jessie it
seems like Anderson Cooper is preparing
for his next role as the Maury Povich
the next Maury Povich cuz more he's
getting up there
I feel like Toobin sometimes when you
and Juan go at each other and this like
oh man here we go again but they brought
in Subin because a vinetti Stormy's
lawyer got his clock cleaned and he
couldn't take Cohen's lawyer on
mano-a-mano and he was drinking water
and he wouldn't look him in the eye and
he was asking Cooper for help half the
time it was a really not a fair fight
and you can see why I mean you don't
think Donald Trump can hammer out an
ironclad NDA I mean come on it's Donald
Trump this thing is airtight it's locked
down every time he breaks it it's a
million dollar judgment that's a lot of
money and it's not like when you go on
CNN and that's one time you break it
everything you every time you say
something about it you break in and
that's a million dollars so he's a
terrible lawyer he's probably gonna get
sued by stormy for malpractice so we
better have a lot of insurance and this
whole thing where they're teasing they
have a DVD that's revenge porn it's
illegal to do that in California and
then they also have this doctored
lie-detector test video everybody knows
that's doctored so CNN he's saying one's
laughing
I don't know if you want to throw in
with these guys the guy's a joke and you
have CNN whose brand is hard news and
real news and they've chased a Russian
collusion hoax for an entire year and
now that hasn't worked so they're
pivoting to a pornstar if you poll
people and say in the midterms what are
your big issues Russia and stormy are
not issues they've lost the pulse of the
American people and not even Sanjay
Gupta can find that posting there one
can you follow that up yeah well I'd
remember when everybody here at Fox was
so upset about John Edwards hmm Oh John
oh is and then course it led to a trial
I think he was led to a bathroom stall
where he was hiding oh yes but I think
it's also the case that he was there was
a mistrial and was even acquittal on one
count or something like that but it was
a trial and what we have here really
away from all the scandal isn't as a
question as to whether or not this was a
in-kind contribution to the Trump
campaign just before the election 130
thousand dollar payment so I don't think
CNN paid the hundred thirty thousand
dollars I think that was done by Michael
Cohen mr. Trump's personal lawyer so I
think there's a real issue here and
don't forget when you're talking about
oh gosh Bill Clinton pornography CNN
I just think talk about irons that the
right-wing uses to try to distract from
the outrageous behavior at stake here I
think boy both sides it seems to me are
reaching but you don't have to reach to
say as an evangelical Christian right
now you see that especially the
evangelical Christian white women
starting to have some question yeah I
put I put rape above everything else
but that's just me Dana you we always
worry about the trumping blackmail but
it seems like the media is doing most of
the extorting well I think she she
stormy would be better served if her
lawyer was quieter in class he or she
comported herself well in the sixty
minutes interview and I would prefer my
lawyer to just do the lawyering and not
do the punditry because I don't think
it's necessary doesn't help her I also
pulled up today just it's a statistic
when I was on Capitol Hill way back when
and my former chief of staff is here in
the audience we you know we watched that
whole entire impeachment hearings and
all the things that went on in the late
1990s and in 1997 Bill Clinton when this
all started had a fifty nine percent
approval rating which is actually pretty
good a year later after it all went down
all the media coverage all the hearings
everything he in January of 1998 had a
69 percent approval rating so I
understand why Democrats would want to
try to do this because they think it
might work I just know that just from
Republicans learned a big lesson well
III think the lesson is that some some
of these things never rebound
sympathetic effect maybe but they can
also harden viewpoints and yeah I'll
stop there yes I think so